the real estate market is constantly
changing thankfully we have an expert
here to answer all of your questions
let's welcome back to the show harvey
blankfeld with las vegas real estate now
who is also sponsoring this segment it's
great to see you great to be back j.c
thanks for having me back is it still a
seller's market it is definitely a
seller's market we just passed a
threshold where we have a little more
than a month's worth of inventory and
the inventory is climbing up so it's
creeping away from sellers but it's
still very much a seller's market right
now how is how are the mortgage rates
affecting everything well mortgage rates
you know they've gone up significantly
over the last couple of months and
what's happened is buying power has been
diminished for buyers so if you were if
you were borrowing 450 000 3 months ago
your payment now would be about 500 more
a month for that same loan
in that short period of time so it's
it's diminished the buying power
and it is affecting sales somewhat
as far as home prices are they leveling
off they keep going up a little bit
where do we stand with our everyone's so
excited look at the value of their home
right now where is that going in the
future they're still going up right now
and all projections from all the experts
say they're going to continue to go up
over the next couple of years still
in spite of the interest rate move um
and the reason is the supply and demand
there's just not that many houses
there's a housing shortage right now and
and i think everybody should be buying a
home and so there's still demand there
too we talk about housing shortage
first-time buyers out there watching
someone's finally ready they want to buy
their first house but i mean a lot goes
into it they're scared and they hear
about people coming with cash and buying
houses left and right should they get in
the game or wait till things slow down
no you know i think you should if you're
a first-time homebuyer first of all that
first one's the toughest one because you
got to come up with all that cash the
first time after subsequent purchases
after that usually you're taking the
money out of your existing home and just
transferring it into a new home so it's
not you have to write the big check
necessarily the first one is the hardest
one but i would say the new first time
home buyers do this
look for what you can afford don't don't
pay attention necessarily where the
interest rates are yeah you could have
bought more before okay i'm sorry you
didn't get them but don't don't let that
uh not go now i mean proceed now anyway
buy what you can afford don't be
mortgage poor buy what you get for but
do buy because the prices are going to
continue to go up and i don't know when
mortgage rates are going to come down to
a level like they were before i don't
know when that's going to happen so
bottom line just get in the game if you
have an opportunity get in the game
absolutely what's the first step for the
first well first time buyer for me i
think that anybody should have a
qualified real estate agent somebody
with some experience to help them
through the process we love working with
first-time home buyers because i'm
passionate about home ownership i want
people to own their own home i think
that's so important for your personal
financial future it's so important we
can see your passion every time you're
on the show harvard seriously you're
very passionate about what you're doing
we love you for that thank you for
joining us thanks for more information
give harvey a call at 702.20
or go to his website
lvrealestateradio.com
in las vegas now we'll be right back